>> Hi You Tube. I am Josette Sherran, Head
of the World Food Program.
And as you may know, we reach out to 90 million
people every year who don't have enough to
eat and we try to provide them lifesaving
food. With the soaring food prices the bottom
billion are really getting hit hard.
So we have one request here at Davos: fill
this cup. This is a cup from a school in northern
Uganda and everyday we fill this cup for 20
million children in the world. It would cost
three billion a year to say that every child
that goes to school in the world has something
to eat. For most of these kids, this is all
they get to eat every year everyday is one
cup of food. So we're asking it costs a Euro
a week to fill. This is a practical step.
Maybe we can't end human hunger this year,
but can we at least say that no child on earth
goes to school hungry? Can we at least say
that each child gets one cup of food? By the
way, for many of the children who get this
cup of food, it's the only food they get all
day. So that's our request. It's something
practical. Something real. Let's end hunger
for school children so they can listen and
learn and create a new future for themselves.
So that's our request is fill the red cup.